je suis aujourd'hui persuadé que s'il ya
des aliens très intelligent à l'autre
bout de la galaxie mais vraiment été
gens vous avez pas comme nous alors
c'est forcément ce scrutin de condorcet
randomisés qu'ils utilisent
il ya cinq ans je vous disais que
scrutin de corsair ronde au musée était
non seulement mon scrutin préféré mais
qu'il était aussi assurément celui que
des extraterrestres utilisait et bien
non j'ai un peu changé la vie même
complètement je vais faire aujourd'hui
un peu mon auto des bonnes qui est je
vais même faire mieux que ceux là encore
je vais vous présenter un nouveau site
web appelé tournesol pour la
présidentielle 2022 qui vous permet de
voter selon un scrutin que je considère
aujourd'hui être meilleur que le scrutin
de condenser randomisés en fait je pense
même qu'il s'agit du scrutin du futur et
je vous invite à vivement y participer
en vous connectant à l'adresse tournesol
point apps l'âge présidentielle 2022 ou
en cliquant sur le lien en descriptions
pour en commentaire épinglé et je suis
sérieux allez cliquer dessus
faites le
je vais attendre que vous le fassiez
avant de continuer
alors pour être clair de scrutin de
condorcet randomisés reste un scrutin
génial incroyablement naturelle et avec
des propriétés extrêmement importantes
notamment vis-à-vis des alternatives non
pertinentes et du vote utile cependant
comme d'ailleurs tous les scrutins que
j'ai mentionnés dans la série sur la
démocratie il a un défaut majeur un
défaut qui rend son champ d'application
était beaucoup trop restreint un défaut
rédhibitoire
vous voyez de quoi je suis pas
en gros le scrutin de condorcet
randomisés mais aussi les autres
scrutins classiques comme jugement
majoritaire ces scrutins ne sont
applicables que six le nombre total
d'alternative qu'on considère est très
raisonnable pour une élection
présidentielle parmi douze candidats ça
passe très bien mais se limiter à ce
champ d'action c'est avoir une vision
beaucoup trop restreinte et de la
démocratie en particulier et de la
gouvernance globale collaborative de
façon plus générale chaque année ce
n'est pas une décision parmi 12 options
que nos sociétés doivent prendre la
gouvernance globale c'est une affaire de
millions de petites décisions à prendre
chaque jour sur quel verdict donné lors
d'un procès quelle norme écologique
adopter quel programme scolaire choisir
quels partenaires commerciaux préférées
quelles sanctions imposées aux
puissances étrangères criminels ou
encore quel mix énergétique favoriser
entre autres en particulier chaque jour
les algorithmes de recommandations des
réseaux sociaux doivent trancher des
milliers de milliards de dilemmes
éthiques sur quels contenus ils doivent
modérer et surtout quel contenu ils
doivent amplifier massivement auprès de
leurs milliards d'utilisateurs à travers
le monde vont-ils mettre davantage en
avant la haine et les appels à la
violence voire au génocide où vont-ils
suggérer des appels à la paix à la
sympathie et à la bienveillance
aujourd'hui ces dilemmes éthiques sont
trop souvent confiés à des politiciens
trop souvent corruptibles à des
algorithmes beaucoup trop opaque et
incontrôlable ou à des dirigeants
d'entreprises privées qui trop souvent
n'ont aucun compte à rendre à la société
civile y compris quand ils commettent
des actes illégaux et criminel si on
veut empêcher les abus immoraux dans ces
milliers de milliards de décisions à
prendre chaque jour il va nous falloir
une gouvernance globale permanente et
pas juste de se réveiller tous les cinq
ans pour choisir entre la peste et le
choléra or malheureusement tous les sous
et un classique dont on a parlé dans la
série sur la démocratie sont peu adaptés
à une telle gouvernance globale
permanente de nouveaux scrutins sont
nécessaires et justement depuis deux ans
la fantastique équipe de tournesol et
moi même avons travaillé dur pour
concevoir le scrutin du futur un scrutin
capable de prendre collaborativement un
grand nombre de décisions par jour et
après l'avoir appliqué dans le cas de la
recommandation de contenus sur youtube
depuis quelques jours nous vous
proposons de l'appliquer au cas de
l'élection présidentielle de 2022
dans le cas de la présidentielle de 2
les alternatives à comparer sur
tournesol ne sont autres que les
candidats à la présidentielle et bien
sûr la question qui nous intéresse le
plus c'est de savoir quel candidat selon
vous devrait être président cependant
plutôt que de vous identifier un
candidat ce qui peut pousser à ignorer
voire a volontairement mal comprendre
des alternatives et plutôt que de juger
les candidats individuellement ce qui
peut plus et trop rapidement des
jugements extrême et un manque de
raisonnement contractuels tournesol vous
propose de comparer les différents
candidats à la présidentielle par
exemple si vous deviez atuellement
choisir entre hutus et la salle lequel
préféreriez-vous lequel de ces deux
candidats choisiriez vous mais aussi
tourner au sol vous demande de vous dire
à quel point avez-vous un avis tranché
bien sûr vous pouvez nous dire que selon
vous ces deux candidats sont exactement
équivalent mais est ce vraiment le cas
n'est-il pas au moins une petite nuance
entre ces deux alternatives par ailleurs
une option que tournesol vous propose
c'est de justifier ou plutôt disons de
documenter votre préférence pourquoi
préférez vous un candidat à l'autre sur
quels critères se fonde votre jugement
il n'y a t'il pas des bémols que vous
souhaiteriez exprimé pour cela tourne au
sol vous propose de comparer les
candidats selon différents critères
secondaires pour encourager ce réflexe
parmi nos contributeurs nous avons listé
trois critères obligatoires de
comparaison à savoir énergie et
environnement éducation culture et
information et santé et bien-être mais
vous pouvez aussi aller plus loin avec
les critères optionnels de comparaison
que son institution et démocratie
travail et économie solidarités et
inclusion et politique international en
renseignant ces informations vous ne
nous permettrait de mieux comprendre les
jugements de nos contributeurs sur deux
aspects en premier lieu on pourra
identifier ce que nos contributeurs
apprécié chez certains candidats et ce
qui leur pose problème par exemple le
candidat d'europe écologie les verts est
il celui qui a les meilleures
propositions pour l'énergie et
l'environnement en particulier que
pensée scientifique du domaine de son
programme voilà qui me semble très
important à clarifier pour mieux décider
collaborativement des politiques du pays
en second lieu et de façon tout aussi
intéressante à mes yeux ceci nous
permettra de mieux comprendre quels sont
les critères les plus importants à vos
yeux en particulier quels critères
déterminent le plus le jugement de nos
contributeurs selon le critère
principale où dit on pas autrement quels
aspects du programme des candidats
détermine de plus selon vous si ces
candidats devrait devenir président
voilà qui permettrait de beaucoup mieux
comprendre comment prioriser la
couverture de l'information par les
différents médias en prenant par exemple
davantage le temps de clarifier les
sujets qui selon vous sont les sujets
les plus importants pour la gouvernance
du pays et alors comme vos jugements
pour des candidats à la présidentielle
ce sont des zones est assez sensible on
a décidé sur tous nos sols de ne pas
donner l'option de rendre ces données
publiques
vous pouvez donc fournir vos jugements
en toute sérénité bien sûr nous publions
toutefois des statistiques agrégés sur
notre site web pour rendre public le
jugement collaboratif de nos
contributeurs après le tour de
l'élection présidentielle il nous
espérons également que nous disposons de
suffisamment de données pour aboutir
également à une publication scientifique
mais donc du point de vue de tourner au
sol ce dont nous disposons pour chaque
contributeur c'est d'une liste de
jugement comparatif entre des pères de
candidats selon différents critères
comment ces jugements sont ils
transformés en score par candidats et
surtout à ton les bonnes propriétés
d'indépendance ou alternatives non
pertinentes et de robustesse au vote
utile donc je vous êtes en parler dans
la série sur la démocratie quel est le
scrutin utilisé par tourner au sol
alors malheureusement les détails du
scrutin sont un peu trop sophistiqué
pour que je vous explique là comme ça en
trois minutes pour les matheux parmi
vous on a récemment soumis est mis sur
arxiv un article de recherche qui décrit
la partie principale de ce scrutin co
écrit avec oscar wilmots et rachid dira
oui et surtout avec youssef aloi qui
l'étudiant de thèse auteur principal du
travail derrière cet article on a appelé
le scrutin utilisé mais et stan qui
signifie le grand lieu en farsi la
langue iranienne et qui fait référence à
un proto parlement qui datent de 247
avant jésus-christ ceci étant dit je
peux vous présenter les grandes lignes
du nouveau scrutin qui est composé en
quatre phases en premier lieu vos
préférences individuelles sont inférées
de vos jugements autrement dit pour
chaque contributeur on associe à chaque
candidat et son chaque critère un score
qui vise à être aussi cohérent que
possible avec les jugements de ce
contributeur en second lieu on effectue
une normalisation collaborative des
scores des différents contributeurs pour
que ces scores soit sur des échelles
comparables c'est vraiment là la partie
la plus compliquée de l'algorithme qui
est d'ailleurs la contribution principal
de l'article de recherche en troisième
lieu pour chaque candidat à la
présidentielle et pour chaque critère on
agrège les scores normalisé venant des
différents contributeurs avec une espèce
de médiane en gros chaque contributeur
qui juge le score trop bas va le tirer
vers l'euro et chaque contributeur qui
le jugent trop enfin le tirer vers le
bas jusqu'à ce qu'on trouve un point
d'équilibré où les forces des différents
contributeurs c'est nul alors ce que je
viens de décrire la correspond en fait à
une médiane et en pratique on utilise un
truc un poil plus compliqué que la
médiane qui a de meilleures propriétés
je voudrais expliquer tout ça dans une
vidéo plus détaillées sur le scrutin en
tant que tel enfin en quatrième lieu à
partir des scores globaux des différents
candidats selon les différents critères
on détermine comment agréger les
critères secondaires pour obtenir une
bonne estimation du critère principal à
savoir devrait être présidente ou
président le score final le score 10
tournesol été obtenue en combinant le
score global selon le critère principal
avec une agrégation des différents
critères encore une fois je simplifie
beaucoup de choses mais les grandes
idées du scrutin sont bel et bien là les
alors at-on l'indépendance aux
alternatives non pertinentes et à ton la
robustesse au vote utile et bien la
réponse est que techniquement non
cependant on s'en approche pas mal et
intuitivement les bonnes propriétés de
méthane viennent du fait que chaque
contributeur tire le score des candidats
vers le score qu'il ou elle juge être le
score adéquat du candidat avec une force
maximale et intuitivement ce
contributeur ne peut donc pas faire
mieux en prétendant avoir des scores
différent des scores qu'ils ou elles
jugent adéquat bon en fait techniquement
c'est bien plus compliqué que cela est
en fait on n'a pas exactement
l'indépendance aux internes et une dont
pertinente ni la robustesse au vote
utile mais ce que j'ai surtout envie de
vous montrer c'est qu'il ya néanmoins
une certaine forme de robustesse que des
alternatives plus simple non pas enfin
dernière question que vous pourriez me
poser est ce qu'on a vraiment là le
scrutin ultime est ce la bonne façon de
concevoir une gouvernance collaboratif
permanente notamment pour des problèmes
plus complexes que la présidentielle
comme par exemple la recommandation de
vidéos sur youtube est ce le scrutin que
les extraterrestres utilisent et bien
sans rentrer trop dans les détails j'ai
envie de dire qu'on a là un bon point de
départ mais qui reste un travail
monumental à effectuer pour améliorer le
scrutin et le rendre plus à même de
gérer la variété extrême des milliards
de dilemme auquel nos sociétés sont
exposés chaque jour tout en garantissant
la sécurité du scrutin vis-à-vis des
contributeurs malveillants donc non on
est encore très loin du scrutin ultime
et il va vraiment falloir que les plus
brillants cerveaux au monde travaille
longuement dessus pour conçoivent
collaborativement une solution à la
gouvernance collaboratif permanente
conforme notamment au principe des
représentants algorithmique dont on a
parlé dans un épisode précédent il nous
reste donc beaucoup de travail mais pour
le coup il s'agit je pense du plus
fabuleux de tous les chantiers jamais
entrepris par l'humanité est en tout cas
la quête du scrutin ultime c'est
vraiment la seule direction de recherche
qui m'enthousiasme pleinement
ceci étant dit pour en arriver là pour
un jour disposer d'une solution
pragmatique sécurisée et efficace pour
la gouvernance collaborative aujourd'hui
on a désespérément besoin de chacun
d'entre vous je vous demande que dis-je
je vous supplie de ne pas être que de
simples spectateurs la gouvernance
collaborative ne tombera pas du ciel on
a besoin de chacun d'entre vous pour la
concevoir et surtout pour encourager les
millions de chercheurs journalistes
militants fonctionnaires et politiciens
à travers le monde à la concevoir et
aujourd'hui la meilleure chose que vous
pourriez faire pour nous aider à y
arriver c'est montrer que c'est un sujet
qui importe pour vous que vous voulez
que les chercheurs s'intéressent
beaucoup plus à concevoir une
gouvernance collaborative et efficaces
et sécurisées plutôt qu'améliorer les
performances d'algorithmes déjà hors de
contrôle et pour y arriver pour montrer
votre attachement à l'éthique et la
sécurité des algorithmes je vous invite
à nous aider vous pouvez par exemple
donner à l'association tournesol qui en
associant un but non lucratif je vous
invite aussi clean je vous supplie tous
contribué à tournesol en fournissant vos
jugements éthiques chaque contribution
que vous ferez à tournesol c'est un pas
de plus que tournesol fera faire plus de
respectabilité et de crédibilité
académique qui permettra de convaincre
les chercheurs à travers le monde de
prioriser la quête d'une gouvernance
collaborative à la quête d'algorithmes
performant qui sont en fait plus
probablement exploiter pour faire la
désinformation de masse s'il vous plaît
je vous en supplie participé à tournesol
comparer des vidéos sur tous nos seuls
points at elle dit nous ce que vous
pensez des candidats à la présidentielle
sur tous nos sols point ap slash
présidentielle 2022 la recherche en
sécurité et en éthique des algorithmes
vous en sera profondément reconnaissante
merci davance